[موسيقى]
تنطلق الشمس في رحله سنويه من الشمال الى
الجنوب على شكل بندول فوصولها الى اقصى
ميل لها شمالا دخول الصيف الفلكي ب 22
يونيو ووصولها الى ادنى ميل لها جنوبا
دخول الشتاء الفلكي ب22 ديسمبر ومرورها
على خط الاستواء مرحله الاعتدال الربيعي
والخريفي ب 22 مارس و22 سبتمبر والشمس تمر
على اجزائم من اليمن وسلطنه عمان
والسعوديه والامارات وهي طالعه فوق وتمر
عليهم مره ثانيه وهي نازله تحت فهذه
المناطق هي مناطق عبور في رحله الشمس
السنويه في رحله العمر والايام مسرعه لا
تنسى من انت او ما وجهت
السفري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبما ان الشمس خلال هذه الفتره تتعامد على
المسطحات المائيه في بحر العرب وعلى ادائم
من اليمن وسلطنه عمان والسعوديه والامارات
فان مناخاتها خلال هذه الفتره تتسم بسرعه
التغيرات بسبب التباين الحاصل بين درجتي
الحراره العظمى والصغرى والفوارق الضغطيه
ولا تستقر اجوائها الا بعدما تنصرف الشمس
والعامه يقولون لا حر الا بعد الانصراف
وحين ذاك يبدا هبوب الرياح الصيفيه
المسماه برياح السموم هبت رياح الصيف
وتغير الجو وانا وليه في ميداني سمومه يا
شمس غيبي واختفي من ورا نوم لا تشرقي يا
شمس كوني
رحومه
[موسيقى]